[Musik]
Liebe Wohner von Lukas Don jetzt herson
und saporizia werden unsere Bürger für
immer
so Putin heute ein Versprechen und
gleichzeitig eine Drohung an die
Menschen in den annektierten Gebieten
Applaus von moskauz politpromenenz so
ist der Abschluss einer Zeremonie in der
die Annexion der vier ukrainischen
Gebiete höchst feierlich begangen wird
heute Abend eine große patriotismus-show
fürs Volk mitten auf dem Roten Platz
herzlich willkommen zu einem ZDF Spezial
Russland verschiebt also gewaltsam
Grenzen in Europa ein weiteres Mal nach
der Einverleibung der Krim 2014 gleich
reden wir darüber mit der deutschen
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock doch
zunächst Andreas Stamm über Wladimir
Putin und die gefährliche Eskalation
seit Beginn seines Krieges gegen die
Ukraine
Bilder die viele für Vergangenheit
hielten am 24 Februar marschieren
russische Truppen in die Ukraine ein ein
Krieg großer Landstreitkräfte mitten in
Europa
unser Ziel ist nicht die Besetzung der
Ukraine sondern nur ihre
Entnazifizierung und Entmilitarisierung
sollte sich da jemand einmischen wollen
und uns gar bedrohen dann wird unsere
Antwort unmittelbar erfolgen und zu
Konsequenzen führen die einmalig in der
Geschichte sind
der Westen soll sich raushalten die
nuklear-streitkräfte werden in
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt Putins Plan
in wenigen Tagen in Kiew ein schneller
Regimewechsel mit Gewalt doch der vormar
stockt hohe Verluste weniger Landgewinn
als erhofft Anfang April muss die
russische Armee sich teilweise
zurückziehen Zweifel an moskauzstrategie
und Stärke kontert Putin mit Verweis auf
den vermeintlich Haupt
die NATO begann mit einer aktiven
militärischen Erschließung der Gebiete
die an unser Land angrenzen auf diese
Weise wurde systematisch eine für uns
vollkommen inakzeptable Bedrohung
geschaffen
Sanktionen die langsam Wirkung entfalten
mehr militärische Unterstützung des
Westens für Kiew das kriegsgeschick
wendet sich gegen Russland Putin droht
mit neuen Waffen und weiterer Eskalation
es genügt wenn ich an dieser Stelle nur
das neue hyperschallwaffensystem Zirkon
anspreche es ist weltweit einzigartig
und kennt kein Hindernis
das größte Hindernis eine veraltete
verunsicherte Armee im Spätsommer
beginnt die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
eine militärische Niederlage denkbar der
Krieg der laut Kreml Herrscher noch
immer nicht so heißen darf bedarf nun
einer teilweisen Wehrpflicht verlangt
nach Hunderttausenden neuen Rekruten es
ist unser Schicksal jene zu stoppen die
nach Weltherrschaft streben die unser
Vaterland stückeln wollen und unter
Jochen unser Schicksal auch diesmal ich
glaube an ihre Unterstützung für eine
Mobilmachung für Annexionen im
Schnellverfahren möglicherweise für
Sabotage Akte an europäischer Energie
und digital Infrastruktur die Ukraine
soll an den Verhandlungstisch zurück so
Putin heute die große Frage wer will und
kann mit diesem Mann reden und über was
tja und in Berlin spreche ich jetzt mit
der deutschen Außenministerin guten
Abend Frau Beerbach
schönen guten Abend was bedeutet für sie
die Annexion der ukrainischen Gebiete
heute
an der Rechtslage hat sich nichts
verändert an der Realität hat sich
nichts verändert der russische Präsident
hat jetzt ein weiteres Element seiner
Hybriden Kriegsführung hinzugeführt und
wir werden die Ukraine weiterhin
verantwortungsvoll bei ihrem Recht auf
Selbstverteidigung unterstützen es ist
auch ein Ausdruck dessen dass der Plan
das hat man ja gerade in den Beitrag
gesehen den der russische Präsident
ursprünglich hatte ganz schnell die
Ukraine einzunehmen dass der nicht
aufgegangen ist und das ist Ausdruck
dessen ist wie stark auch die
internationale Gemeinschaft dagegen
gehalten hat weil es eben nicht nur in
Angriff auf die Ukraine ist sondern ein
Angriff auf die europäische
Friedensordnung und die Karte der
Vereinten Nationen wladimir Putin hat
heute wiederholt das Gebiet gehöre jetzt
zu Russland er werde es mit allen
Mitteln verteidigen wie ernst nehmen Sie
die Drohung vor allem die Gefahr einer
atomaren Eskalation
wir haben die Äußerungen von dem
russischen Präsidenten vom ersten Tag
dieses Krieges ernst genommen aber wir
haben uns davon zugleich nicht
einschüchtern lassen weil er ja immer
wieder versucht hat uns mit Drohungen zu
erpressen zu verhindern dass wir die
Ukraine unterstützen auch die nuklearen
Drohungen die hatte ja vorher schon mal
ausgesprochen gehabt das muss man immer
reflektieren man muss mit
verantwortungsvollen Entscheidungen
vorangehen aber wir müssen uns auch mal
wieder vergegenwärtigen was die
Alternative wäre wenn wir die Ukraine
nicht unterstützen würden dann wäre
dieser Krieg keineswegs beendet sondern
das wäre das ganze Land jetzt in dieser
furchtbaren Situation wie die besetzten
Teile bisher schon in einer furchtbaren
Situation sind mit schlimmsten
Kriegsverbrechen mit zum Teil Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass unsere
internationale Solidarität weiterhin
aufrechterhalten wird zum einen mit
Waffenlieferung damit die Ukrainerinnen
und Ukrainer sich verteidigen können
aber auch mit humanitärer Hilfe und mit
der weltweiten Solidarität die
Auswirkungen wie die globale
Ernährungskrise gemeinsam international
anzugehen und deutlich zu machen der
russische Präsident hat sich hat sein
Land vollkommen international isoliert
Putin hat die Ukraine heute aufgefordert
Verhandlungen aufzunehmen die
annektierten Gebiete will aber nicht
zurückgeben kann es überhaupt noch eine
diplomatische Lösung geben
was sollen das für Verhandlungen sein
man besetzt ein Land man bringt Menschen
um man geht mit völkerrechtswidrigen
Referenten vor und der Generalsekretär
der Vereinten Nation hat das ja heute
eindringlich unterstrichen für die
gesamte Weltgemeinschaft das sind keine
Referenten gewesen das ist Erpressung
gewesen deswegen wird kaum ein Land
diese Referenten überhaupt anerkennen
und das macht umso mehr deutlich dieser
Krieg könnte sofort beendet sein wenn
Russland diesen Krieg beenden würde dann
wäre Frieden aber wenn die Ukraine jetzt
aufhören würde zu kämpfen das macht
dieser heute Tag ja auch deutlich wenn
man sich diese Rede anhört dann würden
weitere Menschen ermordet werden in der
Ukraine dann wüsste man nicht wo der
Krieg auf andere Länder überschwappt und
deswegen ist es eben so wichtig dass wir
auch als internationale Gemeinschaft dem
russischen Präsidenten klare Grenzen
aufzeigen
die Ukraine hat heute die schnelle
Aufnahme die NATO beantragt wie wird in
Deutschland wie wird der Westen
reagieren
dass die Ukraine diese Wunsch hat das
wissen wir ja und das ist auch in der
Vergangenheit deutlich gemacht worden
dass natürlich die Türen der NATO offen
stehen wir haben aber von Tag eins
dieses Krieges auch gemeinsam als
NATO-Mitglieder als EU-Mitglieder als G7
deutlich gemacht dass es zentral wichtig
ist dass wir die Ukraine jetzt bei ihrem
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
unterstützen dass wir zugleich als NATO
aber nicht Kriegsteilnehmer werden und
deswegen unterstützen wir mit
militärischer Hilfe sind aber selber in
diesen Krieg nicht eingestiegen weil das
ist ja genau das was wir jetzt bewahren
müssen gemeinsam den Frieden die
Friedensordnung in Europa die Ukraine
führt ein Krieg auch für oder verteidigt
ihr Land für den Frieden in Europa
deswegen unterstützen wir Sie und haben
zugleich die Verantwortung dass dieser
Krieg sich nicht auf andere Länder
ausweitet vielen Dank Annalena baerbock
danke ebenso alles Gute
tja wie reagiert der Westen Russland
trete die Karte der Vereinten Nationen
mit Füßen so US-Präsident Joe Biden über
die amerikanische Sicht Claudia Betz
vom weißen Haus eine karge Mitteilung
der Inhalt allerdings ist deutlich ein
betrügerischer Versuch einer Annexion
Russland verletze internationales Recht
alle müssten den Menschen in der Ukraine
beistehen
Außenminister blinken sagt die USA
würden diesen schamlosen Versuch der
landname niemals akzeptieren
diese Gebiete sind und bleiben Teil der
Ukraine und die Ukraine hat jedes Recht
sein Land und seine Leute zu verteidigen
und das Land zurückzuerobern das
Russland an sich gerissen hat
die Antwort scharfe Sanktionen gegen
Vertreter der russischen Regierung und
des Militärs Abgeordnete außerdem gegen
internationale Zulieferer von
militärgern die Liste umfasst hunderte
Personen und Firmen was aber wenn Putin
das Unsagbare tut Nuklearwaffen einsetzt
der US-Geheimdienst hat darauf keine
Hinweise Präsident beiden aber mahnt
Putin eindringlich
das würde das Wesen des Krieges
verändern wie nichts seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg
die US-Regierung betont immer wieder
dass sie eine solche Eskalation
unbedingt vermeiden wolle die Reaktion
viele dennoch deutlich aus
wir haben dem Kringel direkt privat und
auf sehr hohe Ebene mitgeteilt dass
jeder Einsatz von Atomwaffen für
Russland katastrophale Folgen hätte und
wir haben klar und präzise gesagt was
das beinhalten würde
öffentlich macht die Regierung das nicht
doch so viel sagt beiden ein Atomkrieg
kann nicht gewonnen werden und darf
niemals geführt werden
ja und zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt der
ehemalige deutsche Botschafter in
Russland Rüdiger von Fritsch guten Abend
guten Abend wie ernst defensiv Putins
Drohung die annektierten Gebiete mit
allen Mitteln verteidigen zu wollen wie
weit wird er gehen
nun dieser eine Satz in der gesamten
rede ich würde sagen das war ein Minimum
an Pflichtübung ansonsten keine neue
Drohung es war eine insgesamt
revanchistische Rede die ausschließlich
eine vermeintlich große Vergangenheit
beschwört von einem Mann der seinem Volk
eben keine Zukunft anzubieten hat ein
Mann in der Defensive zugleich dürfen
wir natürlich die Möglichkeiten
Russlands nicht einfach vom Tisch
wischen unterschätzen in der russischen
nuklear Doktrin ist festgehalten dass
Russland berechtigt ist auch nuklear zu
eskalieren wenn es einen Konflikt damit
zu seinen Gunsten beenden kann nur das
hätte Russland seit sieben Monaten schon
tun können und wer im Moment
Hunderttausende von Soldaten mobilisiert
der wird wohl eher geneigt sein den
Krieg konventionell weiterführen zu
wollen und Zeichnen der Weise hat
Wladimir Putin heute seinen Sprecher
noch einmal die nukleare Eskalation
maximal vom Tisch nehmen lassen
die Feierlichkeiten heute zu Annexion
sollten ja eine Demonstration von
Geschlossenheit und Stärke sein steht im
Kreml wirklich alle hinter putinskurs
ja es war interessant das Publikum
soweit es gezeigt wurde zu beobachten
praktisch keine Generalität die gezeigt
wurde der Patriarch wurde nicht gezeigt
das mag viele Gründe haben da saß
mancher dem ich in Moskau begegnet bin
und von dem ich weiß dass er vernünftig
denkt eigentlich aber hier entsteht eine
Wagenburgmentalität sie alle sind
Gefangene dieses Systems sie leben auch
in Furcht vor Vladimir Putin nur er muss
natürlich befürchten dass eine an einem
bestimmten Punkt des Widerspruch geben
ihn kann denn er ganz alleine hat sein
Land in diesen schrecklichen Krieg
geführt und wenn er mit einem schlechten
Ergebnis nach Hause kommt dann könnte es
sein dass ihm jemand versucht in den Arm
zu fallen ja was und wer könnte das sein
wer könnte Putin überhaupt noch stoppen
nun zum einen er sich natürlich selber
erkannt diesen Krieg beenden und wir
wollen ja auch nicht ausschließen dass
an einem bestimmten Punkt wenn das
weiter nicht zu russlandsgunsten
verläuft er in eine Abwägung kommt was
will er seinem Land zumuten was kann er
durchsetzen und dann sagt erklärt er
Sieg ich habe hier vier Gebiete zu
Russland zurückgeholt wie er das nennt
und bietet dann Waffenstillstand an aber
dann kommt es darauf an wer hat in einer
solchen Situation die starken Hebelende
Hand die Ukraine kann sich nicht auf
einen Waffenstillstand einlassen so wie
in Vladimir Putin heute formuliert hat
auch ein diktatfrieden aber es ist auch
nicht auszuschließen wie gesagt dass es
in Russland zu Widerspruch kommt gegen
ihn sei es aus der Führung da kann man
vor allem ans Militär denken oder weil
sich an einem bestimmten Punkt der
Widerspruch in der Bevölkerung doch zu
vernetzen beginnen sollte bei die Opfer
so groß werden und die Schuld Russland
so offensichtlich
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung Rüdiger
von Fritsch
sehr gerne
Spezial zu der heute in Russland popös
zelebrierten Annexion der ukrainischen
Gebiete über die neue Eskalation im
Ukraine Krieg berichten wir heute später
auch im heute journal hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit Bettys Diagnose auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]